der Bundesverteidigungsminister ist uns
zugeschaltet guten Abend Herr pesturius
guten Abend Frau Slomka sie kennen die
Kritik dass die Ukraine zum tja zum
Gewinnen zu wenig zum Verlieren zu viel
bekommt haben das bisher eigentlich
immer zurückgewiesen wenn dieser Vorwurf
formuliert wurde warum ist er eigentlich
falsch nach der aktuellen Lage na ich
habe ihn immer zurückgewiesen weil er
tatsächlich falsch ist wir liefern was
wir können das gilt für fast alle
anderen Verbündeten und Partner auch wir
haben gerade das Problem das ist bekannt
dass die Rüstungsindustrie in bestimmten
Bereichen nicht so schnell liefern kann
wie die Bedarfe da sind das beginnt bei
der Munition das geht weiter über
luftverteidigungssysteme wir liefern als
Deutschland wahnsinnig viel wir sind
inzwischen der zweitgrößte Unterstützer
mit großem Abstand vor den anderen und
das betrifft vor allen Dingen die
Bereiche die für die Ukraine jetzt im
zweiten Kriegswinter so wichtig sind
also Luftabwehr Luftverteidigung und so
weiter aber Herr wenn wir so wahnsinnig
viel liefern und überhaupt alle lief was
sie können dann hieße das ja im Prinzip
dass der vereinte gemeinsame Westen
alles liefert was er kann und nicht in
der Lage ist einen Angriffskrieg
zurückzuweisen das ist nicht gerade eine
beruhigende Vorstellung na ja wir sind
erstens ja nicht Bündnispartner der
Ukraine das heißt wir sind außerhalb
eines bündnisfalls wir reden
gleichzeitig über einen Russland das
trotz Sanktionen weiter produziert wenn
auch nicht das hochmodernste Material
aber es ist ja nicht so dass wir nur
liefern und aus Russland nichts Neues
für die russischen Streitkräfte
nachkommt das ist halt der Verlauf eines
Krieges wie man ihn nur schwer
vorhersehen kann und deswegen sind wir
in der Situation in der wir sind und
deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir
weitermachen deswegen ist es wichtig und
notwendig vor allen Dingen auf
Nachhaltigkeit der Lieferung zu setzen
bei allen Engpässen die es geben kann
aber warum würden dann die
Produktionskapazitäten nicht massiv
hochgefahren also wenn das die Logik ist
wir müssen jetzt einen abnutzungskrieg
die Ukraine unterstützen das ist ein
Krieg der Ressourcen
Russland produziert was es nur kann und
das ist eine ganze Menge sehr viel mehr
als die Ukraine warum werden diese
Produktionskapazitäten nicht
hochgefahren warum fängt die
Rüstungsindustrie jetzt nicht an Panzer
im großen Stil und ähnliches zu bauen
das tut sie ja sie fährt hoch die
Kapazitäten wo immer sie kann aber sie
wissen ja das ist eine Frage des Tempos
und das Tempo kann man nicht unbegrenzt
beeinflussen das braucht Zeit eine
Fabrik hochzuziehen die entsprechende
munitions und explosivstoffvorräte
anzulegen um dann schnell und zügig
produzieren zu können wir haben es
gezeigt wie schnell das ging bei der
Gepard Munition die wir in Deutschland
neu auflegen mussten in der Produktion
das hat aber auch sech Monate gedauert
das heißt wir reden über Zeitabläufe die
man beschleunigen aber nicht komplett
auser Kraft setzen kann aber ist es
nicht eigenartig dass die Europäer noch
nicht malhr schaffen ihre eine Millionen
Artilleriebeschuss artillerieschuss bis
früher nächsten Jahres bereitzustellen
ich meine die gesamte EU schafft das
nicht das ist doch eigentlich
beängstigend ja es ist aber weniger ein
Problem der Europäischen Union ich habe
sehr früh vor dieser Zahl gewarnt weil
ich sah dass diese Zahl mutmaßlich nicht
würde erreicht werden können
das ist eben man man schürt eben
Erwartung die man am Ende nicht erfüllen
kann eine Million war für eine
Rüstungsindustrie die aus Friedenszeiten
kommt eben nicht so ohne weiteres
herstellbar dass das jetzt in den
nächsten Monaten besser wird davon
können Sie ausgehen wir werden allein
aus Deutschland fast 200.000
schussmunition liefern und in den
Folgejahren das aufwachsen sehen aber es
braucht halt alles seine Zeit und das
ist keine Frage politischer Entscheidung
oder finanzieller Mittel na ja was man
liefert ist ja schon eine politische
Entscheidung also W man nicht Taurus
liefert wenn man Angst hat dass die
Ukrain dann die kerschbrücke damit
zerstören wenn man bestimmte
Präzisionswaffen mit langer Reichweite
nicht liefert wenn man Angst hat dass
dann russische Stellungen außerhalb der
Ukraine beschossen werden sind das ja
politische Entscheidungen ich fand es
ganz interessant dass der frühere
natooberbefehlshaber breedl gerade in
der Berliner Zeitung im Interview sagte
führende westliche Politiker wollen gar
nicht dass die Ukraine diesen Krieg
gewinnt weil sie davor Angst haben nee
das sehe ich genau anders ich glaube wir
sollten eher Angst davor haben dass dass
Russland diesen Krieg gewinnt dass Putin
diesen Krieg gewinnt denn dann stehen
wir vor einer völlig neuen
Sicherheitslage in Deutschland von daher
halte ich diesen Vorwurf für völlig
unbegründet und man kann ih auch nicht
festmachen an der Frage ob man ein
bestimmtes System liefert oder nicht
sehen das denn alle in ihrer Partei und
sieht der Bundeskanzler das genauso oder
wird man nicht vielleicht dann doch
gerade auch wenn man so an nächste
Wahlkämpfe denkt na ja dann doch lieber
auf Verhandlungen drängen die Ukraine
also zum einen sind wir uns alle einig
darüber dass die einzigen die
entscheiden können ob verhandelt wird
oder nicht die Ukraine und Russland sind
und unsere Aufgabe unsere Verantwortung
das sehen wir sehr klar so ist eine
Situation auf dem auf dem Schlachtfeld
auf dem im Kriegsgeschehen
herbeizuführen dass Putin erkennt der
kann diesen Krieg nicht gewinnen und
deshalb an den Verhandlungstisch kommt
aber klar ist wenn wir darauf setzen
sollten wenn irgendjemand darauf setzen
sollte
wir wir verlängern den Krieg oder wir
drängen jemanden zu friedensverhandlung
da muss man wissen dass wenn Putin
diesen Krieg gewinnen sollte wird die
Situation eine andere dann sind Georgien
und Moldawien in Gefahr und das balkum
und das Baltikum könnte ebenfalls folgen
und dann würden wir über einen
Bündnisfall reden und deswegen spreche
ich ja seit einiger Zeit immer wieder
sehr deutlich davon dass wir uns anders
aufstellen müssen aber dass irgendjemand
ein Interesse daran hat die Ukraine nur
halbherzig zu unterstützen das kann ich
in Deutschland mindestens und bei den
westlichen Alliierten nicht erkennen ja
verhandlungseta ist noch nicht mal
erhöht
worden was heißt das na das heißt dass
der in den nächsten Jahren der reguläre
der regul
verteidigungsittentschld ich habe ich
versprochen ja verteidigungsitt der ist
noch nicht mal erhöht worden und die
Haushaltslage der Bundesregierung
darüber brauchen wir gar nicht sprechen
wie wie katastrophal die gerade ist ich
bin da ich bin da ganz entspannt fraulke
zum einen haben wir im kommenden Jahr
wenn der Bundestag das beschließt 71,5
Milliarden Euro für die Verteidigung der
Bundesrepublik das ist der höchste
Betrag für die Bundeswehr in der
Geschichte in der eigenen Geschichte und
ab 27 28 wenn das Sondervermögen
aufgebraucht wird aufgebraucht sein wird
dann wird es Entscheidung geben müssen
die werden im nächsten Jahr vorbereitet
werden und dann muss der
verteidigungseta wachsen damit wir
dieser Verantwortung für unsere
Sicherheit gerecht werden können und das
wissen alle pistorus danke für das
Gespräch sehr
gerne